SPEAKER: How do ideas become industries?
How do inventions become innovations?
How do you break through?
In this course on problem-solving
and new venture creation,
you'll learn how entrepreneurs match
promising technologies with customer
needs to build successful businesses.
You'll acquire new
analytical skills as you
navigate the complexities of
the commercialization process,
moving a technology
from lab to the market.
How will a technology be used?
Is that technology ready?
How will funding be secured?
What is the business model?
Throughout this journey, you'll hear
from a variety of experts, including
founders, funders, and industry
mentors, who will share their advice
and experiences related to
bringing new ideas to market.
Many ideas never move beyond
the lab, and those that do often
fail to achieve commercial viability.
How do we successfully
match seeds with needs?
Join us as we unlock the potential
of promising technologies
and their ability to solve some of
our planet's most urgent challenges.